brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system folks
chris waters here on the front lines at
South by Southwest or in the case of
strafe the bleeding edge i'm here with
tom tom strafe guys made a splash last
year with some hot 1996 graphics and
really a year on in development you guys
have been blowing this game out yeah
yeah we've been really just ramping
everything up we have we went from three
weapons in the initial alpha 2 now we
have about 33 we have 20 enemy types in
the game for zones it's just huge it's
blossoming out and so people are here at
South by getting to play it again to put
those weapons to work and are you is
your mission to like to kill these
people in the game or how have they been
doing cuz this is not an easy game you
guys are making definitely in the game
not reality like don't look into that
the lawyers will be happy no I'm strafe
is a very difficult game we you know we
love the classic shooters we love quake
wheel of doom but we don't like an
impenetrable game we want it to be
something where you learn from your
experience you kind of figure out what
works and you grow as a player so yeah
like we'll see a few people do a few
runs and first time they die in the
first couple of rooms and then they make
it a little bit further than their make
it to level 2 we're constantly bouncing
to make sure it's that fun level of
challenging and not just total [ __ ]
alright well let's look ahead to you
know this guy's been sitting at his
laptop for you know weeks now playing
strafed online what is like what are you
envisioning like a high-level strafe
experience is like like what kind of
systems are in play and what kind of
reflexes etc well one of the things that
we really built the game around is the
idea of speed new players will come
though they'll slowly work their way
through a level but the way we even
handle how you interact with power-ups
how doors work and need the simple
things in the game are all built around
the idea that a skilled player can make
it look great and it doesn't slow them
down so when you're watching someone
who's been playing for a bit it's just
kind of this we make it this great
spectacle that's really entertaining to
watch entertaining to watch and
standing to play are you guys are in
terms of you know leading up to release
what what remains forced rape what
remains to be put in there in terms of
like really flushing out that experience
yeah well we got the core systems down
like that's what we've been working on
for the last year and a half and we've
got all the weapons in we've got most
all the enemies done and completed the
zones two zones three is art complete so
we're just finishing up the end of the
game making sure that's awesome and
we're collaborating with a bunch of our
developer friends to get some games we
really enjoy and there is really cool
secrets so we really like which strafe
the idea is our three pillars are like
speed gore and secrets no particular
order on that and so since we're coming
on early 2017 that really gives us a lot
of time to make sure we get some really
cool ideas in there tell me a secret Tom
I can't Oh May it's a secret for a
reason fine ah tight-lipped Tom here
behind strafe targeting early 2017
release on which platforms pc mac and
linux with oculus support oculus support
because you really want you definitely
want to actually melt a face well you're
probably going to vomit in the oculus
but it's still going to be an awesome
experience those garbage bags handy
folks its strength coming at you soon